so what brings you here tonight when our
consultant what does that mean we
accomplished bank robber Dooley Sutton
was asked why he robbed banks sudden
remark because that's where the money is
[Music]
if somewhere alive today wouldn't be
robbing based you'd be robbing the
wealthy that's very impressive
bingo I'm not gonna do this forever I
think I have two more than I'm done then
I'm out it's adorable
your father was into me for quite a bit
this seems to me like maybe you're
trying to clean up when a dad's messes
you think it goes the other way I want
it
what are you talking about come on you
could use my help mercury I'm Karen
Elise kids have a great time
you're such a cute couple thank you
why are you following me FBI in the past
three years you and your pals have taken
down over 75 million dollars in black
market up what what do you want from me
[Music]
the man with the plan
this one is big one more little job and
you and me undone what are the options
my options are die or not dying okay
[Music]
recently you're not tying me
don't slip up it might not be you it
might be a unstable girlfriend I pulled
a brother
there's always crack
now about a moment of silence
[Music]
how many more loads chew on it do
you